Every year, I hatch so many chicks.
Hundreds and hundreds of chicks.
One of my favorites of the year is chick action season.
I'm gonna get my incubators from the feed store across this one
TikTok show.
The design is similar to the other 3 60 incubator that I have.
There's a few tweaks.
I prefer. This one has the turning motor on the top,
whereas my other one has a turning motor on the bottom.
So that means I can completely submerge this one for cleaning. Checks.
You know how disgusting it gets inside after they hatch,
you get a little fuzzy.
I'm really looking forward to be able to completely submerge this
and sanitize them completely.
Looking forward to see how this system works out.
Other than the other 3 60 incubator, has, like,
water channels,
and they're really,
really hard to clean.
This has an opens inside,
so I think that's gonna be another plus for your instruction manual.
Told you exactly how to set everything up.
Hatch these eggs on as part of a school project,
and this little calendar is gonna be perfect
to help us track when the eggs are gonna hatch.
Think about it.
Comes with simple instructions. When you turn it on,
it's on the pre set settings to hatch tricks,
which is easy if you haven't hatched before,
so you don't have to mess around.
But there's some simple instructions here until you adjust.
This model also comes with an automatic Egg Turner.
Press the. The plus button right here to test your egg Turner.
Also comes with a super convenient egg candle,
so I don't have to be hunting around
trying to find a flashlight when I wanna candle my eggs.
This one's actually got a really heavy bloom on it,
so it's hard to see.
And it's so bright.
So when you wanna candle your eggs,
you do wanna turn your lights off.
And it's super bright here in the sunroom right now,
so I'll do this in the dark.
This incubator holds 22 eggs,
and I might even be doing some egg stack in this season.
So follow along to see that.
To see how many eggs I can get to hatch in this incubator.
Grab yours today. To hatch along with me,
click on that orange car and order yours today.